Today I will speak with Congressman Rubén
Gallego representing the
7th district of the state of Arizona. We will talk about the
election of the coronavirus pandemic
and much more.
In Florida, in Texas, in your
state of Arizona, are you confident
at this moment that the Hispanic population is
not going to be intimidated or that there are going to
be attacks to lie to the
population so they don't vote, well, I think
there are attacks now for more information
and to deal with
the shakes that do not vote
especially that they do not vote because
we have information that is coming from
right-wing politicians in Colombia and
speaking ill of our quality
expression dance but that he is a
socialist that is not true
and at the same time we have  To others, be
aware that they come from Russia, but I
think that they have to take it,
this choice has to matter.  The most
important thing in the lives of the two Latinos,
we already know what happens when
we have leaders who don't know how to
work, who don't know how to be
president,
that's why the Latin comma has more deaths,
government uncini to arrest for our
population, and I think that's why  We are going to
see many bastions that you are
going to vote for, we are going to vote to stop him and against this
leader or someone said measure as it
is no longer when I spoke with his colleague from
Florida we already saw carson corporal she spoke
a little about the misinformation and he
news  directed specifically to
Latino voters because it is in your opinion
that this is being directed to the
Latino population is because it is considered
to be a population of
particular importance in this election because it is very
important because if the Latino community
votes for dance then barnard danced
because  We have a lot of power in the
states that have a lot of the
electoral votes, for example here in Florida,
Arizona, Texas, but there are also many populations.
ions such as the time in the state of
you can from the press came and georgia
to the russians to the
right-wing businesses in colombia and other friends of
donald trump who assures that he
wins again and that is why they are focusing
on our community me  It worries a little
when I see the polls of
Latino voters this year
there is less support this year for the
Democratic candidate than in past years, for
example,
there are more Latinos who supported eur and
count in 2016 than what
the polls show are supporting
iovine this year that worries me
number one you believe these polls and number
two because you think there is this
difference this year
I don't believe in slopes I think there was
a time when there were more latinos who
were in support of donald trump
and not the candidate of  the democrats
but when the general campaign began
when he won the main primary in and
when he began talking to the
Latino community to put and sending them information to the
voters yo yo yo  I
saw that those polls moved to
support Yopal. I think it is important that
we as democrats have
to work every year for the Latino the
Latino vote. I think this is
a good reason that we have
to work hard for this community.
Every year we can't just leave
important Latinos who don't receive
information about the vote or about our
positions or else we're going to have
problems and that we had the
beginning of the dream of many of them that year
but they didn't know if they wanted to vote for
qatar you mentioned the importance of the
state of pennsylvania in pennsylvania
up to this corridor 222 cases where
there is a very very important hispanic population
pennsylvania is also the
only state that can decide
this election that does not begin to
count the votes until the close of  the
election on november 3 so it is
possible it is possible that this election
depends on pennsylvania when do
you think we are going to s  To find out the winner of
that state, well,
I think that by talking to friends
who work on the train, they know that we are going to
know in probably one day, two days,
but also the weather, we have
to understand that this is normal in the
elections in Modena in this country.
traffic, many times we did not know who
was the winner for days and we have rules and
laws on the books that say when
we have to have a certification that
someone wins because they have passed in the
past, it is that the news
reports said that someone
officially won  nanín wins
until the electoral start button goes to
and that did not happen until I think that
December 12 upshaw we have
to be ready
and we have to find all the
tickets but it is normal that we do not know
who he is
on the night of  the election that is the
history of jobs that has happened
many times we should not allow ourselves to change
the message of that or in principle it
is not a problem he does not know  r the day of the
election not because it is not like the
private president and if someone wins they do not
spend present and look at me gradually the
new president does not start until January 20
and if we need to have two or three days
to help that each ticket is counted
We understand waiting three or four days
because nothing is going to change in the past,
what they are trying to do
is change the electronic message that
we have to have all the Vosges
sold tickets for that night and if
we are counted some then the
choice is not  It's fair, well, that's not how it is. It
wasn't 2000 in the year 2000 when
it was West versus Work.
my last question when
we speak in English about this topic we talk
about the security of sending the vote through the
mail system leave it in one of the
deposits vote in person at this
time for our  Latino public what
is your opinion of the safest way to
vote the safest way to vote is
to go to some polls and vote
in person iu if you already have a return
a ballot by mail claw and that ticket
and returned to one of  the bucks is to
vote or you could return to one of the
polls
that are open now on
election day but please don't put your
ballot in the mail because we don't know if it
will arrive on time and at the same time
we have a problem with the  supreme court
of this country that is trying to
change the rules
in the middle of a lesson that is why it is very
important that you and your ballot
return to the ballot box or to the center
where all the athletes will count
before the election is over  the
deputy we greatly appreciate your time
and good luck also in your election on
Tuesday thank you very much thank you very much